es la mayor campaña de vacunación en el
mundo hasta la fecha india comenzó este
sábado a aplicar dosis contra el cob y
19 los primeros en recibir la solución
han sido los trabajadores de la salud y
en el primer día se han vacunado a
300.000 personas en más de 3000 centros
repartidos por todo el país el
trabajador de la salud maniquí marc fue
el primero y animó a sus compatriotas a
vacunarse
no hay por qué preocuparse me vacuné y
me siento mejor ahora el miedo también
se ha ido hago bien y todos deberían
vacunarse ya que es la forma para salvar
a nuestro país india espera vacunar a
300 millones de personas antes del mes
de julio la prioridad será para
trabajadores de la salud personas de
riesgo y mayores de 50 años
el plan se lleva a cabo con la vacuna
comisión desarrollada por oxford y
astrazéneca y fabricada en india además
de kovác sin la vacuna india que todavía
se encuentra en ensayos clínicos el
primer ministro- narendra modi celebró
esta nueva fase de la pandemia en un
discurso televisado para todo el país
india va a iniciar la campaña de
vacunación más grande del mundo y
felicitó a los compatriotas por esto era
árabe india tiene una población cercana
a los 1.400 millones de personas y es el
segundo país más poblado después de
china tras eeuu es el territorio con más
casos de coronavirus superando los 10
millones y aunque actualmente se
encuentran lejos de los peores momentos
de la pandemia cuenta con más de 150.000
fallecidos
la vacuna será un reto con un 69 por
ciento de la población que asegura no
tener prisa en aplicarse en la solución
contra el cob y 19